let's do some more limit examples
so let's get another problem see if i
had
the limit
as
x approaches
let's say
x squared
uh let's say
minus 6 x
plus 9
over
x squared minus nine so the first thing
i like to do whenever i see any of these
limits problem is just substitute the
number in and see if i get something
that makes sense then we'd be done uh
well usually we'd be done i don't want
to make these sweeping statements
if if the function is continuous we'd be
done but let's say if we put the 3 in
the numerator we get 3 squared which is
minus 18
plus 9. so that equals 0
and the denominator also see 3 squared
minus 9 that also equals 0. so we don't
we don't like having zero over zero
and my pen tool is malfunctioning again
so we don't like getting zero zero zero
so is there any way we could simplify
this expression to maybe uh get it to a
an expression that when we evaluate it
at x equals 3 we actually get something
that makes sense well whenever i see two
of these polynomials here and they look
just by inspecting them relatively easy
to factor i like to factor out because
maybe you know there's the same factor
of the numerator and the denominator and
then we can simplify it so let's say
that this is the same thing as
let's see that looks like it's x plus
three
no no x minus three that's my so let me
scratch that this is x
minus 3. it's actually looks like it's x
minus 3 squared but we're just going to
write x minus 3 times x minus 3 which is
of course x minus 3 squared
and then the denominator you know how to
factor these this is
x plus 3
times
x minus 3.
all right
so the limit as x 3 of this expression
is the same thing as the limit
as x approaches 3 of this expression and
of course
this ex you know there's nothing we can
do to change the fact that this this
function or this expression is undefined
at x equals 3. but if we can simplify it
we can figure out what it approaches
well if we assume that x is any number
but three we can
cross out these two terms because then
they wouldn't be zero right it only is
zero when x is equal three because so
the numerator and the denominator could
cross this out and we can say
and i'm not being very rigorous here but
this is kind of how it's taught and i
think you get the intuition that this is
the same thing as the limit
as x approaches 3 of x minus 3 over x
plus 3.
now let's just try to stick the x in and
see see what we get well in the
numerator we get three minus three we
still get zero
but the denominator here we get six
right three plus three is six so now we
get a good number zero or six well
that's a real number so it's it's
it's zero zero six is zero so that was
interesting the first time we did it we
got the answer zero over zero and now we
get the answer uh zero by simplifying
but of course it's it's very important
to remember that this expression is not
defined at x equals three it's defined
everywhere but but if we were to graph
it and i encourage you to do so you
would see that as you get closer and
closer to x equals three the value of
this expression will equal zero and i
know what you're thinking well this was
zero zero is every time i get zero zero
is every time i get zero over zero gonna
end up just becoming zero when when i
evaluate the expression well let's
explore that
let me clear this
let's say
what is
my pen is not working okay the limit
as x
approaches
of
let's say it's
x squared
let's say it's x squared
minus x
minus 2.
all right
now let's say x squared plus x minus 2.
as you can see i do all this in my head
and i i'm prone to mistakes and all of
that over
x
minus 1.
well once again if we just evaluate it
let's what happens when x equals 1 you
get 1 squared
plus
1 so it's 2 minus 2 you get 0 over 0. so
once again we get 0 over 0 and we have
to do something to this maybe
to simplify it well let's factor the top
so that's the same thing as the limit
as x approaches 1 of well that's
x minus 1
times x plus 2 right
let's do x x minus 1 times x plus 2
and x minus 1. and i think you'll often
discover when you see a lot of limit
problems that even if if if this top
factor if this top expression is hard to
factor
chances are one of the things in the
denominator that are making this
expression undefined is probably a
factor up here so sometimes you might
get a more complex thing that isn't as
easy to factor as this but a good
starting point is to guess that one of
the factors is going to be
in the bottom expression because that's
kind of the trick of these problems to
just simplify the
expression so once again if we assume
that x does not equal one and so this
this expression would not be zero and
this would not be zero then
this
these two could be canceled out and we
get that this is just the same thing as
the limit
as x approaches one
of x plus two
well now this is pretty easy what's the
limit as x approaches one of x plus two
well you just stick one in there and you
get three
so it's interesting when we we we just
tried to evaluate the expression at x
equals one we got zero over zero and in
the previous example we saw that uh it
evaluated out when you simplified it to
zero and in this example it came out to
three and i really encourage you if you
have a graphing calculator graph these
functions that we're doing and and see
and show yourself visually that it's
true that the limit as you approach say
x equals one actually does approach uh
the limits that we're we're solving for
and make up your own problems
and
hell that's what i'm doing so you could
yeah you could prove it to yourself so
let's do another
let's do one that i think is is pretty
interesting
let's
oh okay there you go all right let's say
what's the limit
as x
approaches
infinity
the limit as x approaches infinity of
let's say
x
squared
plus
three
over
x
where'd my pendulum go over
x to the third
so the way i think about these problems
as opposed to infinity just think about
what happens when you get really really
really large values of x and kind of a
cheating way of doing this is if you
have a calculator even if you don't have
a calculator put in huge numbers here
see what happens when x is a million
see what happens when x is a billion see
what happens when x is a trillion and i
think you'll get the point you'll see
what if there is a limit here you'll see
what it's going to but the way i think
about it is in the numerator kind of the
fastest growing term here is the x
squared term
right
this is the fastest growing term here
in the denominator what's the fastest
growing term well the fat denominator
the fastest growing term is this x to
the third
well what's going to grow faster x to
the third or x squared well yeah x to
the third is going to grow a lot faster
than x squared so this denominator as
you get larger and larger and larger
values of x is going to grow a lot
faster than that numerator
so you could imagine if the denominator
is going much much much faster than the
numerator as you get larger and larger
numbers you're going to get a smaller
and smaller and smaller fraction right
it's going to approach zero and so as
you go to infinity
it approaches
zero
i know that's i kind of just hand waved
but that's that's really how you think
about it another way you could do it is
you could actually divide this fraction
uh you could actually divide this
rational expression and you'll get
something like 1 over x plus something
something something and then you'd also
see oh well the limit as x approaches
infinity of 1 over x is also 0.
let's do one more i think i have time
i'll do this fast so i can confuse you
the limit
as x approaches infinity of
let's say
3 x squared plus x
over
x squared minus 5.
these problems
kind of look confusing sometimes but
they're really easy you just think what
happens as you get really large values
of x well as you get really large values
of x
these small terms these ones that grow
that don't grow as fast as these large
terms kind of don't matter anymore right
because you're getting really large
values of x and in this case these don't
matter anymore and then these two x
terms grow at the same
pace right and they'll always be kind of
growing in this ratio of three to four
so the limit here is actually
that easy it's three fourths so what you
do is you just figure out what's the
fastest going in the term on the top
what's the fastest growing term on the
bottom and then figure out what it
approaches i mean if if they're the same
term then they kind of cancel out and
you say the limit approaches
three-fourths it's a very non-rigorous
way of doing it but it gets you the
right answer see in the next
presentation